speaking of going forward to the
election
we actually have some what i think is
overall very good news
and news that is extremely triggering
for the president of the united states
donald trump the second and final
presidential debate is this thursday
and candidate microphones will be muted
during the initial answer periods when
the other candidate is speaking this is
not going to apply
during the open discussion period you're
still going to have back and forth
during the open discussion but as you
might remember
during the first presidential debate
donald trump just would not stop
talking interrupting joe biden it wasn't
clear whether trump was
sort of manically outbursting or whether
it was a strategy to try to throw biden
off or a combination of the two
but it made the debate worthless in
terms of hearing policy ideas although
it does seem to have hurt donald trump
in polling because of his childish
petulant behavior
so when the we then after that first
debate
had the commission on presidential
debates announce
that what should have been the second
debate would happen be a video
conference because trump had
coronavirus and trump said i'm not going
to do it remote they can silence you
whenever they want
if you do that and he backed out of the
debate altogether so we now have one
debate to go
the last debate scheduled for thursday
night and indeed during the initial
two-minute answer periods
the microphone of the candidate not
speaking will be
muted the commission on presidential
debates
said in a statement that quote we
realize after discussions with both
campaigns
that neither campaign may be totally
satisfied with the measures announced
today
one may think they go too far and one
may think they do not go far enough we
are comfortable that these actions
strike the right strike the right
balance
and that they are in the interest of the
american people
for whom these debates are held now
there were some people who soon after
the first debate
and people started calling for the
muting of microphones said
if you mute the mics it's not really a
debate if you mute mics it's sequential
talking points it eliminates debate it
eliminates the possibility
of a back and forth this is a balanced
approach
in the sense that of each 15-minute
block
four minutes will be reserved
exclusively for one candidate or the
other
after the four-minute period two minutes
two minutes for each candidate
then the microphones are open it's open
discussion so i think it will undeniably
make the debate more watchable
there are people wondering whether it's
really even better for biden
one would imagine that letting biden
kind of lay out his ideas uninterrupted
will help him
and i think it would the counter is does
it help him more
than the damage trump does by just
talking over biden during those initial
couple of minutes
biden could have helped himself by
speaking uninterrupted but trump
really cratered in the polls after that
first debate
in the end again there will be time for
both
four of each 15 minutes will be
including mike muting so it's a
relatively small adjustment
bottom line these are the updated rules
and donald trump is already not pleased
he said yesterday to reporters after
being told about this change
i'll participate i just think it's very
unfair
trump also spent time at a rally in
prescott arizona yesterday attacking the
moderator
of this week's debate who is kristen
welker take a listen to that
another real great one another great one
kristen welker she's a radical democrat
look at them they're getting angry
she's a radical democrat she deleted her
entire account everything is deleted
but i've known her she's been screaming
questions at me for
a long time and it's just no good
so trump attacking the moderator there
and then reportedly the president is
also not happy that as he sees it the
topics were changed
trump kept saying the debate thursday
night was on foreign policy
and now for example coronavirus is a
topic
i always thought that foreign policy was
not the subject of thursday night's
debate but trump is angry claiming they
changed the topics
on him so bottom line um i think there's
a chance trump does back out
i would put it probably at about 20
percent i hope he doesn't i hope this
debate does happen
but it's very funny how for months
donald trump had been saying oh biden's
gonna find a way out
biden's brain's not working he can't
handle debating me
and then it's trump who bailed on debate
number two
and it's trump who's not pleased with
the guidelines for debate number three
now a serious question and a lot of
people are asking about this
is trump going to just try to interrupt
anyway
even if he's off mike my guess is if
trump tried to do it yeah it would look
very bad
but you would be able to probably hear
donald trump's voice if he tries to
interrupt
interrupt joe biden picked up both by
joe biden's microphone maybe as much as
by the moderator's microphone so i think
it's something trump could do
um i think if he does it it would look
very very bad and reports are that
trump's advisors and
people prepping him for the debate have
been advising him not to interrupt
and to sort of try to be more likeable
uh even if trump likes the idea of being
more liked as i'm sure his ego would
would like donald trump has a very hard
time controlling himself and donald
trump has a
very hard time listening to people who
give him advice because he thinks he
knows better than everybody so my
prediction is
that in nashville 9 p.m eastern on
thursday night which is when the debate
starts
my prediction is that trump's behavior
will be very similar to what we saw in
debate number one at the beginning he
might be more under control
i think he will eventually lose it i
hope you will watch the debate with me i
will be streaming live on youtube twitch
and facebook
starting maybe 30 45 minutes before the
debate
join me then and we will take it all in
together if you're not going to watch
the debate
i'm curious about why let me know on
twitter where you can find me
at d pacman i want to take a second to
tell you about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other protective gear for covet and
they're giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over 150 dollars you can get
there by going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david